I have searched for answers to the following question, but could I find any? So I'm asking you here.
That's exactly what this is for. So I understand the function of black,
sav, bloodroot, what it is used topically. But how does it work to help a cancer patient
if it's used internally? So black, sav, bloodroot, understand is the name of a supplement. So the
supplement that we have, that's called black, sav, bloodroot, maybe shouldn't be called that.
Okay, well, why is it called that? Well, it does have, have a burdock root in it,
grabiola powder, which is the leaf of the grabiola, chaperal, and it has bloodroot powder.
So those four things are all known natural cancer killers. Bloodroot is an herb,
so it doesn't grow here in Minnesota, but it grows in different parts of the world.
I looked it up once, trying to look at how I could grow bloodroot. And I don't remember all the
data that I found, but I gave up on trying to grow it myself. Burdock root grows everywhere. But
I have enough burdock root, burdock plants, my 20 acre property to probably feed the world
in cancer treatment. So burdock grows everywhere. It's a deep, deep rooted plant.
Trying to pull a burdock plant out, and you will, you'd have to get the seventh
regimen army to help you pull the thing out. The burdock roots go down, you know, 10, 15 feet
into the soil. It's really, you have to really dig them out to get the root. Actually made some
burdock root tincture last year, was it, or the year before, when we also had black wallets, we have
black wallet tree. So we made black wallets, burdock root, something else of the tincture
mulled. I think I had, because we grow mulled, and I can't remember something else. But burdock
root is known as a great cancer killer. Graviola is sour sap, and it's the leaf of the
Graviola plant that's a great cancer killer itself. And chaperale is another cancer killer.
The chaperale, I believe, is an seacte, as well as an hoxy. So those are just four great natural
cancer-killing herbs. Now, black sap, topical, is actually made from blood root. So it's basically
dried blood root that is made into a sap with some sort of emulsifier, and then you put that on
topically to kill melanoma and other skin cancers. It could be really good for it as a topical.
I know people who have actually taken the black sap, orally, I think it's a waste of money because
black sap itself is expensive to buy it, made up as a sap, and you could get the powdered blood
root for pennies of the dollar to what you're paying for the black sap. So that's not a smart way to
take it. But the black sap blood root capsules that you're talking about here are not just blood
root, and it's not sap. So I don't know why they named it that. It's just the company named it that.
This company also makes black sap that I recommend the black sap with the MSO for people with
topical cancers, and maybe they did it just to help people understand that this is a topic,
this is an oral quote-unquote black sap, well, it's not a sap, and it's not only blood root,
but that's just what they named it.